let's talk a little bit about what's
going on with Trump's Pro a
post-election planning there have been
these rumors that Donald Trump has
mostly been setting himself up to create
a right-wing media network ahead of
losing the election if indeed he loses
the election and the polls are not
looking good right now the Financial
Times is now reporting that Donald
Trump's son-in-law Jared Kushner has
already started informal discussions to
start a sort of Trump TV network the
report specifically says that Kushner
has already contacted re Birkhoff the
founder and chief executive of Lion tree
lion tree is a boutique investment bank
which often invests or advises uh cable
television and other media deals etc and
the Trump electorate if you could
coalesce them into a TV audience could
definitely be attracted to you know that
the Trump brand of nuttiness but the
Financial Times says that cable
companies might not be hugely
enthusiastic about a new Trump TV cable
network because of cord cutting that's
going on and we've talked about the
problems that the big cable companies
are having so then Trump could go the
direction of starting an online news
operation but that probably wouldn't
command as much attention and there
would be a lot more competition as we
see an online news so I wonder if
Trump's followers will number one ever
figure out how Trump really set them up
to just be used right the the Trump
supporters now are just being used by
Trump maybe to become president of the
United States without really uh giving
giving a flying whatever about them and
if Trump doesn't win and he's just going
to use them potentially at least the
rumors are and we've now heard about
this conversation involving jared
kushner potentially to bring in money to
a television network if and when this
happens my headline is going to be
self-proclaimed business genius starts
television channel nearly two decades
after the Internet age begins uh even
more and more suggestion
from this conversation that this entire
campaign this entire Donald Trump
candidacy was a stunt it started off as
something that Donald Trump probably
figured would get him some attention it
would get him some publicity it might
make it so that he can command even more
of a powerful salary on his next reality
show but ultimately I believe this is
going to blow up in Donald Trump's face
and he will probably be able to turn
into some kind of nice business deal
that is often what Donald Trump does
sometimes it ends in bankruptcy but
sometimes it's a good business deal
personally I don't know that I'd be
watching Trump TV but I do look forward
to hearing more about it if and when and
that's a that that is an if still we
still have to get out there and vote
Donald Trump is uh defeated by Hillary
Clinton on november eighth but so far
the rumor appears to have some weight
behind that if you believe the report
from the Financial Times